just walk up say he looks like you do to
shoeshine
my name is mr. Lee our numbers be four
three eight seven zero a very tall six
six one and they can call you in
Bakersfield your mobile shoeshine you
can call me anytime anytime you're here
telling Tommy the hotel I'll come to
Banco tip i'ma call you come to the big
whoppers shine everyone's shoes love it
man hustle hustle
I bought my first car in 15 years old
she shined shoes and throw the San Jose
Mercury News paper on Saturdays and
Sundays I did that
so
I know the charge $70 $7 then you - so
you charge the seven but some people
give you ten okay how about I give you
$100
[Applause]
[Music]
sure
you keep hustling relevant your messages
can impact a lot of people I love your
hustle the great story
keep that on